i kimberly wexler
do solemnly swear that as an attorney
and as a counselor of this court
i will conduct myself uprightly and
according to law
i will maintain civility at all times
and abstain from all offensive
personality
hey guys pete here i have really been
loving the new teasers they've been
putting together for the last six
episodes of better call saul and today
i'm going to talk about the new one that
just came out they've been great because
they don't give anything away but still
manage to make you think about the
biggest questions that are left to
answer they work so well because we know
so much about these complicated
characters but even with that
information it's really hard to put
together what might happen at the end of
the series i suppose they can't really
show any new footage because so much is
riding on what happens immediately after
the closing shot of episode 7. and so
unsurprisingly this teaser is directly
connected to that i'm going to talk
about that and all i've been thinking
about since seeing it so if any of that
sounds spoilery to you then this is your
chance to leave
the teaser is fairly simple it's a
continuous shot of the candle in jimmy
and kim's living room burning while kim
recites what sounds like a lawyer's oath
in voiceover the image of the candle
tells us that this is probably right
after howard's death because it doesn't
appear to be all that much shorter than
the last time we saw it and now it does
have his blood on it there is a hint of
it flickering again at the end this
effect added so much to the scene when
it happened for howard's arrival and
then again for lalo but there's no way
of telling why it's happening again the
words she says aren't terribly important
since it's more about the idea of what
becoming a lawyer means i did look up
the attorney's oath from new mexico
which is a little longer and in a
different order but i would say that
they were going for something like that
a version that would fit nicely into a
scene to me it doesn't sound like
something she would say if she was
testifying in court one of the first
things i thought about was the finale of
season four which opened with jimmy
becoming a lawyer in that scene you saw
that chuck was there to vouch for his
brother and it would make sense since
kim worked for hhm and they helped pay
for her education that howard might be
there to vouch for her what seems like
the most popular theory stems from that
the idea is that there will be a cold
open flashback where we watch her become
a lawyer with howard by her side this
would be dramatic considering in the
present he's lying dead in her living
room because of something that she did
but i think if that turns out to be the
case then it would have to tell us
something new about the characters we
already know kim will be conflicted
about what happened to howard there was
the scene with cliff where she earnestly
detailed how she wouldn't be where she
was without his help all the planning
that went into d-day was about her
believing they could pull it off to get
exactly what they wanted with minor
consequences that would amount to howard
being humiliated but still able to
bounce back jimmy brought this up in the
confrontation before lalo arrived and
howard agreed that he would be able to
recover
and i have to take a minute to tell you
about today's sponsor because no matter
what happens in the rest of this season
or to zoom out even further no matter
what else is going on in the world
everyone's gotta eat that's why hello
fresh is here to make eating better
easier no grocery stores no stressful
meal planning just everything you need
to prepare wholesome delicious meals all
delivered to your door and that's the
thing i love to cook we make most of our
meals at home but planning is a chore we
usually buy way too much when we go
shopping and sometimes it's hard just to
come up with new ideas you can get
mouth-watering seasonal recipes and
fresh pre-measured ingredients delivered
right to your door with hellofresh
america's number one meal kit hellofresh
makes cooking at home fun easy and
affordable hellofresh offers so many
recipes to choose from each week so
you'll never end up in a recipe bruh
don't waste money on foods you don't
need all hellofresh recipes come with
pre-portioned ingredients to make sure
you have just the right amount for each
recipe those pre-portioned ingredients
mean less prep for you and less wasted
food use my link or go to hellofresh.com
and use the code pog peatp june16 for up
to 16 free meals plus three surprise
gifts across six hellofresh boxes plus
free shipping once you click my
description will live update to count up
the purchases
so i don't think that we need to be
reminded of who kim and howard are to
each other or that she might not be okay
with the unintended consequence of him
dying as a result of their scam i think
there would have to be more maybe
something that happens between them at
the courthouse or afterward a situation
or an event that reveals something about
one of these two characters and in a way
it would almost have to be about kim
because howard's story is pretty well
complete that said there are only a
couple of other options it could be
something that they had ray seahorn come
in and record specifically for this
teaser it does work to remind us where
kim was emotionally at the end of the
mid-season finale and i mean here i am
making a video about this because it got
me thinking still i don't think that's
the case because this is similar to the
first teaser they put out where jimmy
mentions a happy ending i already made a
whole video about that and to me it felt
like that was dialogue that we would
eventually hear in an episode it was
more of a when rather than if we'd hear
it kind of situation this feels the same
but i did think i should bring that up
because you never know the other option
is that kim is somewhere else she's no
longer in albuquerque and now she has to
get a state bar license there i'm not an
expert on how any of this works but
after googling around a bit feel
confident that if you want to practice
law in different states you will
probably be required to pass the bar in
the new state you moved to it looks like
there's a uniform bar exam that exists
in new mexico now that allows you to
practice in a few states but they didn't
start using that until 2016.
and i think this is what's most
interesting about this is that the first
teaser with the apartment seemed to be
for the two of them as a couple the
second one which i haven't made a video
about yet makes you think about who
jimmy is and what turning back to saul
during the gene timeline might mean
which at that point the next logical
question is whether there's any jimmy
left behind in there as well that brings
up the idea of characters that can be
more than one thing at the same time and
this teaser focuses more on kim who we
don't have nearly as much information
about i'm pretty much in the camp of
there's no way she dies in this scene
with lalo i guess there's an outside
chance that could happen but it would be
pretty anti-climactic for all of what
they put into this character for me the
question is why isn't she in breaking
bad more than will she live or die we
know there's a part of kim who grew up
wanting to be atticus finch an
intelligent respectable character who
was committed to justice we've seen that
in her desire to help the less fortunate
through her pro bono work we also know
that there's this gisele side of her
that really gets off on the scam and we
most recently saw her choose that over
the straight and narrow path when she
did the u-turn and skipped a meeting in
santa fe to make sure d-day happened
it's hard to say which side wins out now
that lalo has entered the picture maybe
even harder by the fact that there's
survivals on the line lalo killed howard
because he was in the way and once he
interrogates jimmy there's really no
reason for him not to kill them and just
walk away from the apartment to continue
his battle with gus that's where his
focus is and after all they're witnesses
who are also connected and know about
him skipping bail as jorge de guzman
they're gonna have to make themselves
too valuable to kill and in that
situation the gisele side is likely more
useful for her i tend to think that
jimmy will react to howard's death in
the same way he did to chuck's he'll be
unable to process it and will likely
deal with what's in front of him rather
than looking inside and trying to heal
that feels like the path to being the
saul from breaking bad full time but in
this immediate aftermath in their
apartment the thing that's currently in
front of him is the fact that kim might
be in danger and he has this instinct to
protect her we know that this is what is
most important to him and really after
howard's death it's the last remaining
connection to the jimmy mcgill part of
the story plus he didn't know lalo was
still alive so he was caught completely
off guard and is reacting in real time
under major duress which might also turn
out to be important the last time lalo
showed up at their place kim stepped in
to rescue her husband who was
experiencing ptsd she was caught off
guard and had to come up with something
on the spot but she actually knew ahead
of time that this latest interaction
might happen when she met mike and
learned he was alive it's possible she
did nothing because she knew they were
watching them and it felt safe enough
but it seems more like her to put a plan
together just in case if she did that
could provide a twist but i'm not sure
what that could be i don't think kim
will be able to overlook howard's death
or stuff it away like jimmy but she's
not really in a position where she could
pull back lalo is the one driving now
and as i mentioned i don't see how he
could let them both leave the apartment
or even be out of his sight he could
hold one of them as a hostage and let
the other make contact with mike or
something like that kim has basically
put it together that the man that she
met at the el camino is the same one who
saved jimmy in the desert since they
both know him and this is information
lala would be interested in they could
give it up and then they could somehow
conspire to wreck his plans then if they
were able to pull that off gus and mike
would just have to take him out in a way
that never got back to jimmy or at least
he'd still have to be afraid of him when
walt and jesse take him out to the
desert i don't know that they have
another card to play the stakes are
incredibly high they know they're
dealing with someone who is truly a
monster and outwitting him wouldn't
really be enough so back to the candle
and the attorney's oath they remind us
of howard and kim's connection it also
makes it feel like her days of
practicing law in albuquerque are over
which i guess we always knew was going
to happen because we've all seen
breaking bad will the oath be part of a
flashback to remind us of what she lost
and how she lost it a flash forward to
her practicing law somewhere else away
from jimmy or something else entirely i
guess we're gonna have to wait and see i
mentioned the characters being able to
be two things at the same time in her
case both kim and giselle it is
interesting that before she was working
at hhm she ran away from where she was
from to start a better life at the
beginning of this season it would have
seemed that she had built up too much to
do the same thing even just one episode
ago when she had the meeting set up with
cliff and was celebrating with her
husband that she just planned out an
amazing scam with if you had thought
about this situation with gisele's plans
going wrong it seemed possible she might
have had a change of heart and decided
to take responsibility maybe she would
end up disbarred or maybe she would end
up in prison that's the kind of
character we imagined her to be but now
it isn't as clear and her options are
limited i'm sure she left a lot behind
when she ran the first time but this
seems like something completely
different i don't know what will happen
next but the setup has been fantastic i
can't wait to see how it plays out and i
think that's a good place to leave
things let me know in the comments what
you thought about this teaser and what
you think will happen next how will kim
react to howard's death and how will it
make us feel about the character please
like this video if you enjoyed it please
subscribe to my channel if you haven't
already and thanks for watching i'll
talk to you soon